Hi. We now turn to our third way to think
about modeling individuals, and that's
rule-based behavior. So in rule-based
behavior what you do is you just assume
that people follow some rule. And when
you're constructing your model you say,
here's the rule that people follow. So the
Schelling model for instance, right? We
just assume that people moved if the
percentage of the people like them in
their neighborhood fell below some
threshold. That's a rule. Population below
threshold, you move. Standing ovation
model. I have the percentage of people
standing is above the threshold, you stand
up. That's another rule. So we can
contrast rule based behaviour with the
rational behavior. Now remember rational
behavior we assume people have an
objective function. And then we optimize
with respect to that objective
function. We can also contrast it with
behavioral models, where in behavior models
we assume that people have these sort of
biases, that they suffer from. Now of
course, a bias could be a rule. And
rational behavior can even be a rule. But
when we think of [rule based behavior. We
really think of is you know, writing out a
rule. And assuming people follow them.
Only four different types of rule based
behavior in a way. Right? So we look at
fixed. Rule based behavior where you just
assume you follow the same rule every day,
right. And we can think about adaptive
rule based behavior where you'd change
your rule depending on sort of what's
happening. So we can apply these two types
of rules, fixed and adaptive, in two
different contexts. So one context is a
decision context, right. And in a decision
context, my payoff only depends on what I
do. So the only person materially affected
by my choice is me. And so I can have a
fixed rule that I apply in a decision
context or I could constantly be learning.
I could be adapting my rule over time. The
same, second thing we'll consider is
gains, right? So in a game that's a
strategic context. Now my payoff depends
on what other people do. And if my payoff
depends on what other people do it could
be that I don't want to use a fixed rule
and I wanna be a little bit more adaptive.
But if I found works well almost all the
time like in a bargaining section, in a
bargaining situation I may decide to just
to say I'm gonna bid ten percent less than
my value. It could be the easier to follow
that fixed rule because you just think
look it worked for me in the past I'm just
gonna stick with it. So what we're gonna
do in this lecture is just walk through
all four of these cases. That's the goal.
We're gonna walk through all four and just
sorta get some understanding of what
modeling rule based behavior looks like.
So let's get started. Let's start with
fixed decision rules. What would be an
example of a fixed decision rule? Well,
one fixed decision rules that's actually
used quite often is random choice. I've
done a model and I just assume that people
choose randomly. Now why would I do
that? Well, the reason I do that is the
same reason that Myerson gave for, you
know, choosing. Rational behavior.
Remember, rational behavior's a really
good benchmark. It sort of says, what
would super smart people do in this
situation? But we could also take the
opposite benchmark, and assume that people
make completely random choices. And then
we could compare the two. We could say,
well, how does optimal choice differ from
random choice in terms of how the system
behaves? And so, by comparing those two
sort of extreme points, we get a little
bit more understanding of what might
happen or what could happen. Now, that
sort of, not, you know, we think of it a
fixed, normally we think of a fixed rule
it'd be something like, take the most
direct route. So, for instance, supposing
I'm in a city and I'm right here. And I'm
gonna head towards, I wanna head to this
museum up here. So here's this museum,
cool, and we're next to it. And I come to
this intersection and there's a road going
this way, and there's a road heading off
at an angle. Well if I chose the mes, most
direct route. Rule. If it's [inaudible] I
would choose this one. Right? I would head
in this direction. Now it could have been
though, that if I had gone this way, I
would have found a diagonal street that
headed directly to the museum. And it
could be that this street goes up here and
dead ends, and I get stuck. So, following
the most direct route, locally can be a
good rule to follow, but it might be that
there's something better to do. And the
reason I give this example is because when
we think of fixed rules they may not be
optimal. Right, they may be good, but they
may not be optimal. So let?s think about
fixed strategies. Let's compare strategies
to decisions. Remember in the strategy, my
payoff depends on what other people do, so
now a strategy could be something like
divide evenly. So let's suppose I'm in a
bargaining situation, right? So we're
thinking about, you know, thinking about
splitting an asset with someone. So for
example, suppose that there's some land
that, you know, my brother and I have
inherited. And we've gotta decide, okay,
so much do we get? There's 80 acres. Well,
what we could say is, well, let's just
divide it evenly, let's each take 40
acres. That would be a strategy that I
could use in a game, and it can be a fixed
strategy. Now, we can have more
sophisticated strategies. So a strategy
that's described a lot is a strategy
called tit for tat. So in tit for tat,
you can imagine, let's suppose I can be
nice or I can be mean. And suppose I start
out in tit for tat by being nice. And I'll
continue to be nice as long as you're
nice. But if you're ever mean, then I'll
be mean. But then, as soon as you're nice
again, I'll be nice. I'm just gonna sort
of do unto you what you do to me, but I'll
start out by being nice. Now, the reason I
wanna explain tit for tat is because you
can, I'll show you how you can sort of
encode this in the context of a model. So
you can use something called a Moore
machine. And so this one machine works as
follows. I'm gonna put a little star here.
You see, I'm gonna start out by being
nice. Now what this green arrow says, this
sort of describes what the other person's
doing. So I'm gonna stay nice unless the
other person's mean. If the other person's
mean, then I'm gonna come over here and be
mean. And I'm gonna stay mean until the
other person's nice. And if the other
person's nice, I'm gonna go back over
here. So these arrows tell me, if I change
my state from the nice state to the mean
state. So what I can construct is by
writing on this little sort of computer
program, I can take a behavior like tit
for that, and embed it in a model. Now we
can also embed another behavior. This
would be a model of behavior called grim
trigger. Right, so here again I'm gonna
start off by being nice, and here I'm
gonna stay nice until you do something
mean, represented by the green arrow. And
then if you do something mean, I go over
here. But notice there's no arrows coming
out of the mean box, right? This little
mean circle, I just stay mean. So this is
a strategy where I start out nice, but if
you're ever mean to me, that's it. And
this is formally called. Grim. [sound].
Trigger. And the reason it's called mean
trigger is that it, it's pretty grim,
right. If you're ever mean to me, that's
it, I'm mean forever. And the reason it's
called trigger is because all it takes is
one mean action on your part and that
triggers my perpetual meanness. Again so,
what I'm showing you here is how you can
write like just a simple diagram, right, a
computer model to represent rule based
behavior. So those are fixed rules, right?
Now let's go to adaptive rules. What would
an adaptive rule be? Well, let's suppose
that you're, you know, making, like I like
to make chocolate chip cookies,
[inaudible] I make oatmeal chocolate chip
cookies every week. And you're trying to
figure out, okay, how do I make really
good oatmeal chocolate chip cookies? Well,
one approach that people sometimes use is
called a gradient-based method. And so
what a gradient-based method is, is you
keep sort of trying things in directions
that are working. So suppose I keep adding
honey, suppose I start out by adding
one-fourth cup of honey. Right and it
turns out that it's pretty, the cookies
are pretty good. So then I add one more,
one tablespoon more, so it's one more
table spoon. So this is plus. One
tablespoon and one more tablespoon and
it's even better so then I may add another
tablespoon so then I may might add plus
two tablespoons, right and so on. So
gradient based would say if I find a hill
I keep trying to climb it, so that would
be adaptive in a sense and instead of just
following a fixed rule I keep
experimenting and trying to find, find
things that are better. Another type of
experimental rule is let's go back to
remember we talked about random behavior.
It could be that I also tried something
completely random. Like I might throw
wheat germ in, or I might throw raisins
in, or I might throw walnuts in, or I
might do something, just completely crazy.
That's an approach. I just random search.
Again it's adaptive. Instead of following
a fixed rule. Right? I keep changing what
I'm doing trying to find something better.
Trying to make a better decision. Now
where we see the adaptation a lot more, is
in the context of strategy. The reason
that adaptation, and adaptive rules make more
sense in the context of strategies, is
often the other person is changing their
behavior to take advantage of me, so I
change my behavior to respond to them. So,
in the context of a game it's often
important that you use an adaptive rule. So
what would an adaptive rule be? So, one
would be best response. What does that
mean? So, let's suppose that we have some
sort of strategic situation, and the other
person is taking some action. Well what I
could do, I could then. Think like a
rational choice person. I could say "What's
the best possible response I can do". Given
what the other person's doing, and I'm
gonna do that, okay? So that's a rule I
could follow. Because best respond to what
the other, whatever the other person's
doing, alright? What's another thing I
could do? Well, mimicry. The only think I
could do in a game, is, I might not be
able to figure out at all what to do. So I
could just copy other people that are
doing well. So I might look around and
think. I'm not sure it's, you know, how to
dress. Or I'm not sure how to behave in
this situation. I'm not sure how to bid in
this auction. Well what I could do is I
could watch, what are other people doing?
If you just copy what they do. So those
are two really standard ways. One is just
[inaudible] best response. [inaudible],
think of the game, think of the situation,
and then figure out, what's the best
possible think I could do. Right? But
that's going to be adaptive, because if
the other people change what they're
doing, the best possible thing to do next
period could change. Another thing you
could do is just mimicry, to look around
to see who's doing well, and I could copy
people who are doing well. Couple of
observations about rule base B. First,
sometimes optimal rules, are simple. So,
sometimes you might have a situation like
this, where I'm trying to maximize my
happiness. My happiness depends on two
things. Chocolate and movies. And here's
my. Happiness function, right? It's the
square root of chocolate times the square
root of movies. And there's some price for
chocolate and some price of movies and I
could sit down and think okay, what's the
optimal thing to do here? And if I
actually solve for the optimal thing to
do, it turns out I should spend equal
amounts of money on chocolate and on
movies [laugh]. And so, in some cases, the
optimal thing to do is to follow a rule,
and so assuming rule-based behavior isn't
that crazy of a thing to do. You can just
say, let's just assume people spend half
their money on one thing and half their
money on another thing. If I'm writing
down a model of the macro-economy, I might
say, let's suppose that people spend
twenty percent of their money on food. 30
percent on transportation, 40 percent on
housing and ten percent on entertainment.
Well, that may, you may say, well that's
sort of a crazy fixed rule... Well it's
not, because it's actually wrote down some
elaborate utility function and have people
optimize, they do something that's fairly
similar to that. But another thing though
[laugh], simple rules can also be
exploited. Let me give an example. Suppose
my rule is in bargaining, that instead of
demanding half, or asking for half, I say
look initially I want 60%. And then what I
do is I say, okay. Well. Okay. Next
[inaudible]. I'll say fifteen [inaudible].
And I keep going down by one percent each
period. Think about what somebody else
could do if they're bargaining against me.
When they, when I say 60, they say well,
you know, how about 58. And then I could
say well okay, I'll follow my rule and I'm
going to say 59. And they could say well,
okay, 57. And I could say 58 and they
could walk me all the way down until I was
getting nothing because they just walked
me down from 60 to 59 to 58 to 57 to 56 to
55 to so on. So a simple rule can often be
exploited. So let's think and let's give a
quick summary. Why do, why model people
using rules. Well the first one is it's
something really easy to model, right. You
could start to say here's my model. Let's
just assume like in the Schelling model or
in the standing ovation model, let's just
assume people follow the rules. It's
computationally really easy to do and it's
easy to think through what's going to
happen. Second reason, you can capture the
main effects. Often if you sit down and
think how would someone behave in this
situation or how do I behave in this
situation, you think it's a rule and
that's the, you write down that rule and
you're going to capture the main things
that are going on. Third thing now. Often
it's gonna be kinda ad hoc. Right, so one
of the problems in writing these things
down is not everybody's the same as you.
So remember when we talked about the
difficulty involving people? One is that
people differ, and because people differ
so much, any one rule you write down may
be somewhat ad hoc, and it may not
represent what's really going on. And then
the last thing which we just talked about
is sometimes you see rules can be
exploited. And so if you think about a
strategic situation, writing down a fixed
rule can be problematic because if
everybody followed that rule, other people
would really take advantage of it. So
where are we? We've talked about rational
models of behavior where people optimize.
We've talked about more behavioral models
based on observation and even some, you
know, recent neural signs. We now talked
about rule based models. What we do is we
sort of write down what people do but, as
a rule, and then just ask sort of how does
that rule aggregate. Depending on the
situation, any one of these three things
might make perfect sense or maybe you want
to do all three to try to get a deeper
understanding of what's going on. What
we're going to do in the next lecture is
we're going to talk about how in some
cases it's not going to matter very much
what behavioral rule we write down. And in
other cases it could matter a lot.
Alright, let's get started.